اجراءات امنيه صارمه في نيويورك قبل وصول
ترامب
اقمار اصطناعيه تكشف نشاطا نوويا كبيرا في
كوريا الشماليه
ايطاليا تحضر اللغه الانجليزيه وغرامه
ضخمه لما يستخدمها
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من الحدث الابرز في امريكا حيث كثفت
الشرطه اجراءاتها الامنيه في نيويورك
استعدادا لاستقبال دونالد ترامب قبل مثوله
امام المحكمه في قضيه الممثله الاباحيه
شرطه المدينه اعلنت انها تنسق مع محامي
الرئيس السابق وفريقه الامني للتحضير
لعمليه وصوله الى قاعه المحكمه والطرق
التي سيسلكها قادما من برج ترامب حيث
سيبيت ليلته فيه بعد وصوله من فلوريدا
مستوى عالينا من الانشطه النوويه كشفت عنه
صور التقطتها اقمار اصطناعيه بكوريا
الشماليه وبحسب منظمه 30 نورس الامريكيه
فان الصور تشير الى ان بناء مفاعل بالمياه
الخفيفه في موقع يونكيون وشك على الانتهاء
وتشغيله بات قريبا المنظمه اكدت ان هذه
التطورات تعكس على ما يبدو التوجيه الاخير
لكيم جونغ اون بزياده انتاج المواد
الانشطاريه لتعزيز ترسانته النوويه
غرامات ماليه ضخمه تصل الى 100 الف يورو
قد يواجهها كل ما يستخدم اللغه الانجليزيه
او حتى كلمات اجنبيه اخرى في الاتصالات
الرسميه في ايطاليا بموجب تشريعات جديده
التشريعات التي ادخلها حزب اخوه ايطاليا
الذي تتزعمه رئيسه الوزراء جورجيا ميلوني
تعتبر ان اللغات الاجنبيه ولا سيما
الانجليزيه تهين وتذل اللغه الايطاليه وان
العذره الوحيد كان بريطانيا وهي الان لم
تعد جزءا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
جدل كبير وردود فعل متباينه اثارتها نسخه
مصغره من برج ايفل ظهرت فجاه في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وتحديدا في ساحه
المجاوره لموقع برج ايفال الاصلي النسخه
الصغيره اطلق عليها اسم وهي اصغر بعشر
مرات من البرج الاساسي حيث يبلغ طولها
حوالي 33 مترا ووزنها نحو 32 طنا فيما
اوضحت وسائل الاعلام المحليه انه مجرد عمل
فني مؤقت وانه سيزال في العاشر من ابريل
الجاري
نتائج خطيره توصلت اليها دراسه سويسريه
ربطت فيها بين التعرض المستمر لضوضاء
الشوارع داخل المنازل والاقدام على
الانتحار الدراسه كشفت انه ومع كل زياده
من مقدار 10 ديسيبل في متوسط ضوضاء المرور
على الطرق قرب المنزل يرتفع خطر الانتحار
بنسبه اربعه في المئه فضلا عن اثار سلبيه
اخرى باقتراب النوم وزياده هرمونات التوتر
والتغيرات في وظائف المخ